Ethan, have you ever considered the fact that you think it could
just be stupid that maybe it's not malevolence?
>> Connor, Connor, Connor.
Allegedly, according to the clients, do you see anything wrong
with that? Connor, >> you criticize Hassan [__]
That means you must love genocide. Now, Destiny is
Let's start with the Counterpoint stuff. Now, I think his stream
got nuked, so we might have to watch uh
might have to watch this little archive video. Okay, it's not
really about debunking every argument against him, but a lot
of the attacking is coming from pretty dishonest places. Like
the time people claimed that his son urged his viewers to US
Senator Rick Scott. Here's what he >> If you cared about
Medicare fraud or Medicaid fraud, you would kill Rick Scott.
This clip got his son suspended, and many to this day claimed
that he was issuing a death threat towards a US senator. The
issue there is that Hassan is clearly talking to US Speaker of
the House Mike Johnson who's making remarks about how much he
wants to combat Medicare fraud. >> The reason why I'm saying
if you cared about Medicare or Medicaid fraud, you would Rick
Scott and not make him uh a prominent part of the Republican
party. >> So Assan is clearly saying Mike Johnson, if you
actually cared about Medicare fraud, you'd do the opposite of
what you've done with Rick Scott because of how egregious of
an offender he is. Rick Scott is pretty well known for conducting
one of the largest healthcare fraud schemes in US history when
he was chief executive at Colia. So to say Hassan was urging
his viewers to Scott is an outright lie and to say it was any
kind of death threat would also be pretty stupid. So that
okay this is the kind of sweeping that I wanted to that I wanted
to call out.
So, for instance, >> LET'S GO.
let's go.
Conor's going to call it the sweeping. >> Say that I want
to Hassan [__] from a trebuche into the Caribbean.
I'm actually trying to communicate to you that this is sincerely
how much I hate >> Dude, he started this off by commenting
on how Hassan has a 90 IQ. That's crazy that he doesn't understand
what's happening here.
What?
Hassan's not saying this to communicate how much he hates Rick
Scott. He's you. Does Connor not know what Rick Scott is famous
for? Or did he pause too soon? That's crazy.
Conor. Connor. Conor.
So, the the point of the comment is if you cared about Medicare
fraud, you would jail or do something about the worst Medicare
fraudster in America. But instead, you made him a part of your
That's the point. If you Oh my goodness. Not to communicate hatred.
So if I could, I would fly to Los Angeles. I would get like uh
an 18-wheeler
or something. I would throw like dog food in the back of it.
I would on [__] throw him in the 18-wheeler, drive
down to uh Key West where they have the 90 mile sign. I would
spend like a few weeks building a trabushe, probably a few months,
let's be real. So he would just eat dog food and live in an unairconditioned
18-wheeler for a while and then I would build a trebuche and
him into the Caribbean and then hopefully at that point I built
up enough popular support from the federal government that they
uh have the Coast Guard, you know, with like orders of I
Okay, the reason why I use that kind of rhetoric is trying to
I'm trying to communicate the level of that I wish I could visit
upon this man because while I don't think he deserves to die
based off of his behavior, I do think he deserves some level
of but in order to cushion
my of attitude towards Hassan
like let's say Hassan
what is a good example let's say Hassan
did a union busting at like at like Twitch or something like
he participated in union busting at Twitch and and basically
Connor said well if lefties actually cared about unions or organized
labor Assad. That's like the same expression, right? Sort of.
Maybe he'd have to do a little more than union busting, but like
that's at least getting vaguely in the general direction of where
the commentary was.
You know what I'm saying? Like it's it's not quite there cuz
Rick Scott is uniquely evil when it comes to Medicare fraud,
but like at least it gets in the direction. It has a purpose.
It has a meaning. It's conveying meaning. This is 90 IQ chest
and de I don't know what he's trying to do, man. He's like not
even getting close to the mark on what the point of the comment
is. I try to make the scenario so extreme that you guys know
that I'm joking, right?
And so
where's the where's the cushioning of the extreme stochastic
rhetoric in order for us to know that Rick Scott shouldn't be
right. When I covered Hassan Piker's uh Yale, where's the conditional
If Republicans, it's saying Republicans, the conditional rhetoric
is in whether or not you think Republicans care about Medicare
fraud.
That's the conditional rhetoric. They don't care about Medicare
fraud because they put the biggest Medicare fraudster in their
party. He is a prominent member of their party. That is the conditional
part. They don't care. It is evident in the fact that he's there.
Uh Yale speech, I said Fed Post, Fed Post, Fed Post, you know,
terms of service, terms of service, terms of service. But then
half a dozen times throughout the section, I said, "Hey guys,
I actually have horror violence. I think it's bad for the national
discourse. I think it's bad for politics." Dude, is being in
close proximity to these communities, is it like just detrimental
to your mental health? Like to your not even mental health. What
is it? Like your neurochemistry in some way? Like I swear to
God, well, I don't think Connor's like a worldbeater intellect.
Not that I am either. I He's usually capable of understanding
like fundamental concepts.
and something happened. He's just like got brain parasites. He
can't understand the fundamental concept here. And I it doesn't
sound like a performance. I actually don't want anybody to hurt
Hassan [__] I think it's a cool thing in our country
that he has freedom of conscience and freedom of speech. And
if he earnestly believes the things that he's articulating, I'm
proud to live in a society that tolerates this extremess even
though it's personally repulsive to
So where's his caveats?
If I can admit that I use stcastic rhetoric that might encourage
people to view Hassan dis like disfavorably and even have a vaguely
attitude towards him. But wait, but that's not the question.
That's not the question that people call it a direct call to
violence. If you ask Kilo, well, could this possibly be some
like stochastically some step in the direction of people doing
violence towards Rick Scott? I think he'd go, yeah, probably.
Obviously, the fact that you talk about anything you use like
violent rhetoric ever, even in in an allegory, even in metaphor,
that will probably raise the temperature in some way and participate
towards some vague notion that violence is acceptable. Probably
something like this could happen, right? You know what I'm saying?
Like, I get that, but that's not what people are arguing. They're
saying he he said we should Rick Scott, and he didn't say that.
>> Then I caveat it. I add in jokes and I add in disclaimers.
Where's Assan's jokes? Where's his disclaimers?
And this is where this feels like absolute sweeping to me. Okay,
>> I don't that's Man, I can't even do like a good clip
for this. I can't even like get a clip out of this cuz I'm baffled
that Connor is this dumb on this one. This is a rough one, man.
That's just tough to listen to. >> Just one example of
what are very common dishonest attacks on Hassan. There are,
of course, genuine criticisms to be made about him, and we'll
go over a few of them later, but those tend to get lost in this
sea of total hysteria. The widespread derangement that people
have for this guy has over time devolved into attacks on anyone
he associates with, calls for him to be deplatformed. And people
have even become pretty chill with the US government violating
Hassan's first amendment. >> Okay. Uh Froggen, for instance,
who I'm I don't hate Frogan because she's like Hassan Orbiter.
That's one of the reasons why I hate her, but it's not the main
reason why I hate her. The main reason why I hate the she was
like, "Oh, you got PTSD from combat operations overseas. Muslims.
Good. I hope you have PTSD, you loser. I hope you don't get any
medical care. I hope you suffer, you
war imperialist.
>> Okay, this is him seething about Broken, which is fine.
Hour and six. He's talked about CPS
that time. >> I've always
pu >> always said like I have no idea how the happen. It
just makes no sense. And now I see it. I see how it happens.
And Ethan would also regularly take to Instagram to go to war
with H3 Snark, a subreddit dedicated to a logging and talking
about primarily Ethan and Ela. And in January, Ethan released
the >> Okay. January. And then the skulls were sent in
March.
So, you know that I see I don't see these as discreet.
I see these as Okay. Now, I have to watch once Connor gets to
the part of the video where we talk about when
the lawsuits were planned.
What is Connor gonna say based on when the when the content nuke
was registered? Because I do believe the content nuke is registered
January. Yeah. Am I crazy?
So for instance, Ethan and Hassan chron
Ethan and Hassan are friends. They start the leftovers,
bro. And chat full of people saying they want to you and your
wife. It's not too hard to get from A to B. Yeah. What the [__]
does that change about what the [__] I'm saying,
bro? That doesn't
>> Doesn't change about what I'm saying.
>> man, it's um
I'm I don't know how to say this without sounding racist. Okay,
I'm not racist, but I I don't want to sound racist. I don't know
how to say it without sounding racist. I I think there are a
lot of people who have money
and they want content creators to support Israel and they know
how to argue in favor of Israel and they know how to send links
to these content creators and these people will come in to these
communities like Connor's community or like other communities
and they will donate a bunch of money for people who are saying
pro-Israel things and I think that has like a shaping I don't
think it's a conspiracy. I think it's people who are like genuinely
concerned about rising anti-semitism and they'll go to streams
and they will they will literally pay for people who support
Israel and there's like a shaping thing that happens over time,
There's a there's a shaping thing that happens over time where
these audiences like actually change these creators into like
total Zionists, like totally
Zombies. Total zombies. >> Sing like he's an infant. He's
crawling around. He's doing everything in his >> Hold I
want to see this revealed he had registered content nuke with
the US Library of Congress and he's filing copy
>> So when was it registered with the library of congress?
Yeah, January 28th
according to Ethan reacted in a nuke in an way. What started
as a political disagreement has spiraled into three copyright
lawuits a campaign to financially harmed which witch and by consequence
its creators and a long bear and kind of pathetic feud where
you will be forced to pick a side. But before you pick a side
while you may feel some sympathy sympathy for Ethan because of
the very real harassment that he's faced or maybe you just agree
with his takes on Israel or anti-mitism. We have to make sure
we don't forget about the most important thing in the whole situation,
which is that when it comes to Ethan's narrative, this is all
complete. If you can look past some of the political disagreement
and analyze that Ethan and
like, "Oh, I should be paying attention. Let's go." >> It's
pretty clear that Ethan is an insecure, neurotic, vindictive
liar. And his crusades against Twitch and Hassan and subreddits,
these are all just dishonest missions to silence people who are
saying things about him that he rather clown show is being encouraged
and facilitated and other liars around Ethan that have attached
themselves to him. Sometimes just to further their own dishonest
agendas against Hassan. Now, normally, I wouldn't really care
that much if a bunch of lying freaks all band together to help
each other out with their controversies. That's kind of to be
expected. But what elevates my taste for all this stuff and what
should elevate yours is that standards of behavior that have
long been widely held on the internet are being totally abandoned
all in the name of the sound bad. Historically things like lying
harassment calls to the platform or abusing copyright will get
you absolutely torn to shreds. But when it comes to Ethan and
all his yesmen, everyone all of a sudden seems to be okay with
those things. And it's just because of who's on the other side.
Ethan Klein isn't the original. We'll see. Uh I'll allow the
case to be made, but at the same time I
I would be shocked if Keelodonics actually presented new information
that made me change my calculus. I'll let him, you know, make
make the case and I'll try to keep an open mind about it. But
how is it any more complicated? Like like how can you say Ethan
Klein couldn't get ass mad over Hassan, you know, having his
political perspectives in reference to Palestinian liberation.
That he couldn't get mad that the community that he thought he
built with Hassan turned on him and half of them turned on him
and said some violent evil reference to him that his family has
been harassed as a result of this digitally. So they should get
the over it, but they've still been digitally harassed. And when
you're in the middle of a digital tsunami, I've been in like
a digital dog pile two or three times. And luckily for me, I
felt like I was in the right, so I didn't give too much of a
but it's still bewildering when you get like half a doz even
like when you get a dozen quote tweets and half a dozen messages
calling you a piece of [__] and telling you to it
does feel like the entire internet hates you even though it's
like six people and a dozen quote tweets. So what does that feel
like when it's literally hundreds or thousands of quote tweets
and dozens or hundreds of direct messages? You know what? >> Okay,
so all of these things would apply to his son as well, right?
So 15 seconds >> how could he not truly feel like he was
getting dogped on the internet for that he was okay about and
then how could he like I think so if I think and I don't even
need October 73 to think a piece of why the you know I'm I'm
curious I'm very curious >> what what about kilotonic's
line of evidence will either move he's going to argue something
you love Connor and it's personal responsibility
how about we actually apply the lens the conservative
lens that Connor loves so much of personal respons responsibility
to Ethan Klein. Can we hold Ethan Klein accountable for his actions?
I'm sure Connor loves it when somebody holds a woman accountable.
Okay, maybe maybe I'm reading into it and treating him like Myron.
A lot of lot of guys in the internet who are not big fans of
women in general love when women are held accountable. I'm just
asking you as an as an internet collective of incelss and losers
to treat Ethan Klein the way he deserves to be treated,
like a like a whiny woman on the internet. Okay? Just treat him
the way he deserves to be treated, please. That's all I ask.
>> Move me to a more Hassan sympathetic perspective or
make me reconsider my current position. I don't know if the evidence
exists, but I'll I'll look for it. Now, I'm going to pull.
Ironically, I'm going to >> I only said that cuz I know
it's too early in the stream for take to be awake and be watching.
>> Pullan [__] move real quick. Yesterday,
I went to Publix, my local grocery store, which is delicious,
and I got myself some sushi. And Hassan [__] no.
NO, CONNOR, it can't be story time. CONNOR, CONNOR, STOP. I will
not engage in Connor story time. I'm sorry. I'm waiting till
the mo the show moves again. 2 hours. 1:5930 is the next good
time stamp. >> The heavy baby myth extensively, for example,
and has not retracted since >> while being overly skeptical
or just rejecting negative stories about Israel. >> That's
a huge claim. 15 Palestinian women were I couldn't really find
a lot of evidence to back it up. >> I understand why Ethan's
brain would operate this way. And it's like there's anything
immoral about having a bias, but obviously at a certain point
after Ethan makes enough comments like this to a lot of people,
he's going to start to sound like he's defending Israel a little bit,
like kind of reflexively. >> They could have held a ceasefire
at any point. They could have ended it after. Hamas could have
ended the war anytime >> How could have Hamas ended the
war >> by leaving by releasing hostages? >> Hamas
offered all the hostages in agreement for Israel not uh coming
into
>> And this was kind of the sweepy that I wanted to address.
So I'm happy that I stuck around in order to bump into it. Do
you know how that sounds to anybody with a Q above 80?
Do do you understand like sorry for using the arser or whatever,
but do you understand how stupid that is? I come into your country.
Let's >> You didn't use Wait, did you use the arser? Did
I miss him using the array? >> Let's pretend for a second.
A state is a government. A nation is a people. And a country
is a territory. And while the Palestinian nation state is not
recognized by Israel or the United States, we could still use
the analoges of a nation, state, and country to the Gazin territory.
And so Sam, >> that was a harsh of a nation, state, and
country to the Gazin territory. We could still use the
Oh, that was a rough one. That was a rough one. I could detect
those even at 2x, man. That was a rough one, buddy.
Uh
Ethan says, "Okay,
Hamas could have ended. They could have just surrendered." And
then Sam says, "Oh, well, Hamas offered them terms that they
would give up all the
>> No, he said Hamas could have ended the war. They could
have given the hostages back. And then Sam said, "Yeah, they
did. They tried."
You're not even paying attention.
That's a specific reference.
They did try to give the hostages back in exchange for Israel
not entering Gaza. That was not allowed. >> The hostages
were not coming into Gaza. So, let me get this straight. Mexico
could invade the United States. No, but that's what Ethan argued
kind of reflexively. They could have held the ceasefire at any
point. They could have ended it after Hamas could have ended
the war anytime, too. How could Hamas end the war by leaving
by releasing the >> Hamas offered all the hostages in agreement
for Israel not coming into >> By releasing all the hostages
by leaving by releasing all the hostages. If those two things
were required at the same time, I don't know what the rest of
the argument was here, but like Ethan is the one who suggested
this. Okay. >> A state is a government, a nation is a people,
and a country is a territory. And while the Palestinian nation
state is not recognized by Israel or the United States, we could
still use the analoges of a nation, state, and country to the
Gazin territory. And so Sam says, well, Israel could have ended
the conflict at any point. And then uh Ethan says, "Okay, Hamas
could have ended. They could have just surrendered." And then
Sam says, "Oh, well, Hamas offered them terms that they would
give up all the hostages for them not coming into Gaza." Do you
think that's a same deal, Sam? You numb skull. Is this like a
same lefty position? Should I know? Well, he said leave. Ma should
leave and then give the hostages back and that would have caused
the warn to happen.
I That's what Ethan said. And now you're rewriting the hypothetical.
You're rewriting entire
Ethan. Have you ever considered the fact that you think it could
just be stupid but maybe it's not
>> Uh yeah, I considered that for a little bit. Unfortunately,
with the DMCA stuff, as you go through this, it becomes malevolence.
Even if it's not malevolence at this point, it is absolutely
malevolence now. Actually, it was malevolence. Malevolence at
this point once he was debating Sam Cedar was already malevolence,
but it wasn't always bad. It was at some point it wasn't malevolence.
At this point, it is. Maybe he's just a midwe and there are dozens
of examples of this. There's Ela essentially saluting IDF pilots
on Instagram after Israel strike on Iran. Or there's also her
referring to, >> oh no, you're expressing sympathy for
a military operation that prevents Iran from having nuclear weapons.
No, you're just like the Nazis.
Oh, let's digitally harass you and send skulls to your house
and call CPS and say that >> why is he Dude, this is sad.
This is really sad. >> He can't he can't engage with the
>> You're a [__] genocidal monster. >> God,
these people, no offense. Like I don't think Hilo himself is
stupid. Nor has he like forwarded necessarily his argumentation,
but the implication that I'm taking from this is like he was
bad because she showed sympathy for the 12-day war. [__]
you. No, he is bad because
rather than standing up for her principles, which is I believe
the Palestinians should be free. I believe they should have their
own state. She's showing support for the IDF who are objectively
committing war crimes.
>> And plausibly that would lead people to believe that
you support Israel over Palestine, that you are a Zionist. For
Eli, I do believe she's just a Zionist. I mean, she has some
sympathy for the Palestinians. It just doesn't even compare to
the sympathy she has for her fellow countrymen. And I don't know,
there's the probably the argument you should have there is should
she should she have more empathy for the Palestinians than her
own countrymen? I don't even know if that's reasonable, right?
She's probably significantly like severely propagandized.
Like I don't know. I don't know. Yeah, sure. The fact that she
states she does is a lot. It does a lot of the lifting for you.
But I'm just saying that like I understand how that's like tough.
But trying to argue that it's like that it's stupid to think
she supports Israel over Palestine. No, it's not. It's totally
reasonable. Support the state doing a genocide. People will say
you support a genocide. It's just that easy. >> Follow
Christian's advice. Yeah, you can take a minute, too. How about
that? Enjoy your one minute, you son of a [__] Bye.
>> A man who is currently wanted by the International Criminal
Court for war crimes, including directing attacks on civilians.
Nobody made her say that. Nobody made Ethan defend it. But the
Klein seemed to want to endlessly make comments on this very
controversial subject and expect it. >> Okay, here's another
thing about Golant was that during the Gazin operation, allegedly
according to the Klein, Golant was a voice of moderation in the
negotiations.
Allegedly, according to the Kleines, do you see anything wrong
with that, Connor?
Connor, Connor, Connor
allegedly, according to the Clyde saying, "Hey, we shouldn't
go [__] wild. We shouldn't up Gaza. We should actually
have a diplomatic solution here." And they were praising him
for being moderate. Okay. In that spec specific
I don't believe that. I don't believe that ever happened. I don't
believe it.
I don't think Connor believes it. That's not who Yo Golant is.
Like Like that that there's no reason to believe that at all.
If anything, he might have had infighting. I think the infighting
he did with BB was not over. Oh, we should have a diplomatic
solution. It should be it was we need an exit strategy. How do
we get out of this war? If we don't have a plan for where we're
going, we shouldn't be in this war in the first place
was what Yo Galant was saying. Now, what do you think he meant
by a plan?
Cuz I think it was like, are we planning to expel these people
to a certain place? What are we planning to do? That's more along
the line of what Yov Galant wanted for a plan. But what Kilo
and the leftist has presented this as is a blanket endorsement
of everything Galant has ever done or said ever. So if we're
going to be criticizing these for being what about the fact that
what the thing that he said is right after October 7th, if we're
going to talk about Yo Glance's thoughts on Palestinians post
October 7th, why wouldn't we go to the first comments he made?
>> Dishonest, lies of omission, bias, hypocrisy, all that
kind of [__] how about we don't do it ourselves.
And when the clients do something, we provide the context through
which maybe their reasons are not as bad. Right, Kilo? Does that
sound fair? I hope so. >> 258. 250. 250. Hold on. We move
forward.
right here. Connor does not like Noah Samson. Okay. >> It's
about making money by attacking a guy they don't like. >> I
think the terrorism sing might literally be a clip from this
video. So, Kilo, please save it for me. Bring it back. Bring
it back for me, big dog. That was Noah Samson, who I briefly
mentioned earlier. Noah is a 20-year-old video, I say, with over
half a million subscribers. That video came out over a year ago
and no key in on quite a few relevant things. He explains that
when Ethan's commentary on Israel and Palestine is almost exclusively
antagonism towards people who above all else morally object to
the genociding Gaza. It sort of has a function of supporting
genocide because that was the most argument I ever god damn it.
Now I think you're
thought that hit
you criticize [__] That means you must love genocide.
That hit for you? That's disappointing. the sum total of your
political engagement is to help Israel while it's committing
a genocide then
I don't know it's not even a complicated argument contend contend
with the >> very disappointing as Noah puts >> the
arguments they're attacking him for anti-genocide arguments so
these creators you know they're positioning themselves uh in
opposition to him and his arguments the fact they're positioning
themselves on the pro genocide side you know anti anti- genocide
is pro genocide
that was a banger for you that hit wow
holy I didn't >> break it down for me Connor break it down
how dumb was Break it down, >> dude. I didn't know IQ was
the way to
>> I need to change my whole business model, guys. That
was like the dumbest thing I'd ever heard my entire life. And
Kila was like, you know, Noah was he was cooking when he said
that. I'm in disbelief. That was one of the dumbest sentences
I've ever had. Do you criticize the Soviet Union? That means
that you're pro-Nazi. Do you criticize America? That means that
you're pro- jihadist. Do you criticize George W. Bush? That means
that you want to murder his entire What if you criticize the
religion or the ethnicity? What if you're criticizing actions
in Germany while they're being genocided?
What if you were consistently criticizing anybody who was standing
up for and talking about the Holocaust that was happening, right?
Knowing that the Holocaust was happening,
you think that would help a Holocaust continue to happen if you're
continually discrediting anybody making noise about it? That's
the That's the hypothetical here, Connor.
I know it's difficult for you to come up with these hypotheticals,
but you should >> Yeah, maybe he has a football related
injury. Yeah. Do you have CTE, bro? Like I obviously do have
CTE, but like I have the fun CTE. You have the dumb CTE. Holy
[__] that hit for you. Which isn't really that unreasonable.
And we think about it that way. It further illustrates that the
widespread Zionist perception of Ethan is I'm I'm sorry. It was
not that unreasonable. Is that what you just said? No. Anti anti-genocide
is progenocide, which isn't really that unreasonable. And we
think,
>> bro, that's one of the dumbest if you criticize anybody,
you endorse the worst opposite thing of who that person is.
you are consistently for a very long period of time criticizing
the same person for the same arguments they're making that are
in opposition to genocide. In totality, you are supporting that
genocide.
How is this hard? That hit for you. Think about it that way.
It further illustrates that the widespread Zionist perception
of Ethan is really just a product of his own behavior. >> Let's
bring an Iraqi terrorist group to your neighborhood and you just
go out and be and your mom be and your kids be and you alive.
And again, I'm saying that I support Palestine. >> Do do
you think Do you think Ethan Klein has the capacity to bring
Iraqi death squads to America? Do do you think that's something
that Ethan Klein is actually capable of? Do you think when Noah
Samson said told his audience of hundreds of thousands of people
that they had direct physical access to the politicians and military-industrial
complex companies that make the weapons that are currently doing
genocide, do you think that uh those people did have the physical
capacity to commit terrorism?
Yes. Yeah. This is why universal suffrage is a mistake. Truly.
>> Yeah.
No, it called for violence.
Oh, like objectively called for violence. What's the problem?
I didn't call that out. Don't ask me if I thought it was like
a remotely justifiable call for violence. And it's not just creators.
There is an entire network of entities across multiple platforms,
all feeding off each other to spread misinformation and baseless
character attacks about Hassan. Places like LSF on Reddit or
he on Twitter. These function as dedicated anti-Isan news networks
that feedback directly into the machine. The clip gets posted
that creator makes a video on it. The news networks post clips
from those videos. It's this bizarre incestuous cycle of people
just jerking each other off about how terrible his biker is.
It's funny for how much Ethan Klein cries about an organ. I don't
even know if that's true. Let's rewind. Han calls out one of
Jesse's orders food shops for being a Is that is that somebody
off how bad Han Like like listen, I'll buy into the general trend
that Han sucks ass and it's possible to make money calling him
a piece of Yeah, I totally >> Why does that have zero votes?
Connor. Connor. Connor, why does that have zero votes? Connor.
Hey, Connor. Engage with the information on your screen. Why
does that have zero votes? Han really wants an AI toy chirping
Chinese propaganda. Taiwan is an inaliable part of China's territory.
Okay.
5,000 votes. Desty can't stop laughing at Hassan's photo shoot.
4.2K votes. Hzan calls out one of Desty's orbiters food shops
for being an admitted zero votes.
pay attention.
Pay attention to the content you are watching. It is embarrassing
watching you not able to follow. >> Totally agree with
that. Yeah, it's fine. But your your evidence sucks. Wow, Connor,
you're so bad faith. You're
like you criticize me. You know >> how terrible his son
Piper is. It's funny how much Ethan Klein cries about an organized
harassing campaign. You would be shocked at how organized a son
is. Hey, let's go. Ethan Klein, Destiny, Dance Holden. Who else
is there out there that is pushing the Hassan narrative? There
has to be more of us. >> Well, it's happening organically
realizing Hassan is a crazy person. >> he is a bad guy.
I am so happy that I could be part of this movement to destroy
this terrorist. This goes beyond Wait, hold on. Kilo, to be clear,
I hate Hassan organically. Okay, with or without Dan Salman,
with or without the with or without Zionism, I have enough reasons
to hate Hassan. Yeah, Connor's I know kung fu movement. Truly,
dude. I don't Now I want to debate Andrew Wilson about any topic.
Any topic. It doesn't matter. You know how any topic he's like,
"Well, do you believe in God? Do you believe in the Bible?" Well,
if you don't believe in God in the Bible, then you have no orienting
philosophy and therefore it's just a series of subjective preferences.
So why are we debating our subjective preferences when I can
root my ideas epistemologically and metaphysically and you can't
debate over? I should do the well, you're criticizing me right
now and you know
therefore if you really don't think it's that simple with Andrew.
I know everybody likes to characterize it that way. Like they
try to characterize it that way. It's not just that simple.
He argues the subjective preferences. He was like, "You can't
say I'm morally wrong because your morals aren't grounded in
anything." So, we do have to have a debate over these subjective
preferences. That's why he says, "When you try to virtue signal
and say it's morally wrong to take away women's suffrage, I'm
saying no, it's not. You have no subject. You have no objective
morality. You're not even trying to. So, it's just subjective
preferences. Don't try to moralize." I think that's how he argues,
right? I don't think he just says everything you say is bad.
I'm correct on everything because you don't believe in God. That's
not it. That's not what he tries to >> criticize me.
THAT'S THAT WAS THAT WAS THE ARGUMENT.
>> YES, he said. But no, Dude, I go back to his Vosch debate.
Maybe he started doing this more often.
I haven't seen it. Right. But to me, Vosch immediately agreed
to these things, right? Andrew basically was like, "Okay, you
just can't moralize over like any of these things. You don't
have morals. You don't have objective morals. So when you tell
me something's morally wrong, I don't believe you because your
morals are just subjective and they have a hard it's like difficult
to foundationally argue against that and then you're arguing
the subjective preferences. But it's usually just done in contention
with anybody going, "Well, I don't I don't like that. That's
wrong. We shouldn't do that."
Go
airgo you, you know, P equals not P.
It turns everything into like a honestly like a borderline utilitarianism.
Like you're arguing the merits of everything.
[__] thanks, Kilo. You gave me the ultimate debate
topic. How How did I never think of this before? Why did I never
think that anybody who criticizes me is bad and evil? Why? Why?
Why? Why did I just think of that? All right. Cuz you're not
known for being against You're kn for being,
frankly, for being flip-floppy at minimum.
Okay, Connor, you originally said Food Chop should not be in
the space at all. And then you told me that you actually like
Food Shop's content because she alogs me.
You said that. You're flip-floppy at best on Connor. Do not act
otherwise. Okay, that's just true. You have flip-flopped on this
topic. >> It's like an entire ecosystem, but the attacks
on Hassan are also often exaggerated, misleading, or even outright
false. And as we've already seen, there's quite a rag tag band
of liars, and complete morons that are most responsible for pushing
them. So, all things considered, it can be a little difficult
to parse what information about Hassan is actually real. So,
to wrap up, how about this one? How about uh how about Hassan
[__] talking about landlords in the street because
he hates capitalism. How about him sweeping for the Weaguer genocide
when he said that it was tourism hours in Shing Jang where he
pulled up an article that allegedly backed his perspective that
tourism was reopened in the western side of China. But realistically,
what the article actually said was that if you go try to investigate
the cultural genocide in western China, then Chinese state officials
will follow you around and intimidate the local population out
of talking with you. Uh, how about him totally ignoring the fact
that China is credibly accused of harvesting organs from political
dissident? How about, you know, him going to China and being
excited about Mao Dong's little red book being gifted to him
by a Chinese person when Ma Dong is arguably as evil of a villain
in human history as Hitler? Uh, how about uh how about him going
on the podcast with Second Thought in Hakeem and saying, "Oh,
yeah, yeah, I pretend to be like a social democrat and I pretend
to be a normie." >> Yeah, the video is about The video
isn't saying Hassan's awesome. The video is saying that these
people lie about Hassan and here's the most common lies. Those
are the those are the arguments
like picked out a whole bunch of creators who use Hassan as a
as a base to form support for themselves despite being like and
gross disgusting freaks.
Hello. Hello. whenever
my job in the radicaliz
revolutionaries who want to see a true revolution in the United
States. How about all that you How about all that you loser?
I don't even need Israel Palestine. I don't even need the Red
Sea crisis. I don't even need Hezbollah has the best flag. I
don't even need Tento down. I support the
>> So boring. Just so boring. >> I don't even need
Tim Houthy Shalom. I don't even need uh you know his tepid support
of Iran. I don't need any of that. And I can still call this
guy one of the biggest tanky pieces of [__] on the
internet. You goddamn loser. This is embarrassing.
This video, let's go through some of the most sensationalized
and infamous claims about his son biker and see which ones hold
up. Let's start with one of the most widespread and craziest
headlines about Hassan that still gets repeated to this day.
The son visited a brothel in Germany that was rated for trafficking.
Now, this story comes in a few different forms depending on who's
telling it. You've got Dan who very strategically says that his
son visited a brothel that was later rated for human trafficking.
Next talking more aggressively states that the brothel was rated
for the trafficking of at least one and on the most extreme end
of the spectrum. Destiny outright claims that hisan literally
the 15-year-old. So here's what actually happened. A long time
ago, Assan visited the legal Artemis brothel in Berlin, which
is a pretty famous and reputable establishment. In
>> honor, thoughts was rated on suspicion of human traff.
The entire process involves 530 investigators, yielded no results.
In fact, the authorities recommended no changes to the brothel's
employment process or working conditions. And Neil is actually
a
>> This is the brothel owner saying, "Oh, you idiot." I
I I'll try to explain how stupid this is.
>> this is the biggest [__] I literally might
have to read this on Monday because we're running out of time.
>> Club Artemis
>> raid. This might even be the same article. The city
of Berlin has issued an apology to a major brothel and paid $250,000
in compensation over police raid that happened 7 years ago. Hundreds
of police raided the Artemis sauna in Bravo near West Cruz in
2016, detaining several people on suspicion of human trafficking,
tax evasion, and other >> That's I believe that's West
Cit.
>> Crimes like these can be common in the German worker
industry, which in of itself is not illegal. >> Wasn't
the point of this video Kilo talking about how all these people
use bad as justification for their antics? And Connor<unk>'s
response was Hassan Bad, why are you talking about me?
No, no, no. Well, maybe that is the grand total of his response,
but his response right now at least or what I'm seeing is he's
saying, "No, Hassan actually is bad." It's like, well, that's
not really
While Kilo does defend Assad, maybe you could argue he sweeps
for Assad on some things. I think I disagreed on a couple of
the things that he maybe went a little too far in terms of defense,
but it's like all arguable. None of it is outside the realm of
like arguability.
So, but the point of the video is not to say Hassan's awesome.
We should we should let Hassan lead America. The point of the
video is look at these and like
defenders essentially who are going to try to use Hassan as their
like sled out of whatever crimes they've done.
that's what's going on here. That's why it talks about Cameron
who had those weird allegations with
it talks about Naku with all of this with his the Discord and
his obvious like um the EPI empire. Okay. That's why I talked
about techone the
that's why it's talking about these >> conference afterwards
public prosecutors made references to organized crime but the
accusations cannot be proven in court and the Berlin regional
court would not admit the prosecution's case in 2018. The two
operators of the bravel then took the city to court for wrongful
detention before reaching a settlement with the administration.
The state of Berlin apologizes for the pre-trial detention in
the considerable disadvantages suffered by those is Connor going
to take the the arguments they made
at a at a press conference afterwards. Public prosecutors made
references to organized crime but the accusations could not be
proven.
Do we not care that the because I think he says something about
it being organized crime and it's like do we not care about what
they could prove in court at all? >> Those accused of time
has a result of the search. The pre-trial detention, the indictment
and the statements made by public prosecutor's office. The city's
judicial administrative said in a statement on Friday, so I just
want to talk to you real quick about the nature of crime because
this guy's truly a idiot. Okay, we had a drug dealer in our city
who was a lieutenant who stabbed and shot people inside our city
and was credibly accused of doing murder. Okay. He got into a
car with one of his associates at 11 11:00 p.m. at night and
then his
associate was found dead in a ditch in a different city 20 minutes
away at 5:00 a.m. That guy had reason to murder that person.
We did not have the capacity to charge him with said crime because
that's all we had. No witnesses, dead body, no blood in the car.
11 p.m. the dude's alive. Seen in the car of the guy who likely
murdered him. 5 a.m. he's found dead in a ditch. Okay. And yet
if
>> Wait, that sounds reasonable. Like that sounds like
you said 30 minutes away, a city 30 minutes away. That sounds
like okay, maybe so the circumstances make it a little less reasonable.
It's a guy who shot other people. You think credibly you have
information he shot other people. Okay, but just in a vacuum
that situation, there's a lot of things that could happen in
the the difference in time there. That's 4 and a half hours.
This guy could have gone anywhere else. Could have gotten into
a car with anyone
I do think you have to be able to prove something, right? There
should be some something some evidence somewhere. >> You
ask me, did this guy murder his associate? I'm going to say 99.9%
absolutely that guy murdered his associate. If you say, hey,
do you have enough to charge him? No. Do you have enough to prove
it in court? Absolutely not. Okay. So, the point is 20 minutes
away. Bro's got gas money. Surely we'll apply this. I could have
sworn this was Connor, the guy who's like, "No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I can't believe that Destiny did something bad or
I I'm like suspect on this. We need to actually prove this out.
If a court decides this, then you know I'll actually uh I'll
care if court decides.
And now it's like well actually given the circumstances this
guy's really bad. This guy was guilty of murder. Okay. I just
want us to maintain a simple equal standard into the future.
So anyways, can I imagine because Germany is a cucked goddamn
Euro hug thug sweet country that the German prosecutors and I'm
pretty sure there's another article that says that their criminal
connections were Hell's Angels. like it was an American motorcycle
club that they were allegedly engaging in trafficking with. Okay.
And so saying that like oh uh this guy the owner of the club
said after we won a $250,000 defamation suit they didn't make
any recommendations to us on how to change our business operations
and that okay now now Carter now contend with the fact that there
was no minor there when Hassan went with the fact that there's
not even an allegation of that that when Hassan went to this
brothel there was no minor there. There's no allegation of
You are sweeping on some total
right now. What the he doing now? >> That's the person
you quote. Why don't you talk to the state prosecutor? Because
the state prosecutor was confident enough in order to say, "Yeah,
they were associated. They were clicked up to the Hell's Angels.
They were trafficking people." So why don't you why don't you
go see what the actual evidence was? And so this is where it
feels like a total sweet job because you're saying, "Oh, Artemis
is legal. Artemis was accused, but nothing happened." And then
the owner said that the government didn't tell us how to change
our employment practices. Therefore, we were totally innocent.
Therefore, there's nothing to see here. I don't know. Let's think
about this real quick. Isn't Hassan [__] a socialist?
Doesn't he believe that we are all slaves in the capitalist system?
Doesn't he believe in like power dynamics and people being slaves
to capital and therefore having to do work that they wouldn't
want to do? So, wouldn't engaging a woman for work, even on a
voluntary basis under the capitalist system, aren't you essentially
a slave? >> Possibly. How old was Hassan?
He's 18. So, do we believe that Hassan had the sort of set in
stone beliefs about the world that he has now back in this era?
Back in this this time?
You're getting way too offended on Hassan's part. You get way
too upset, man.
I'm saying Hassan, there's no reason to even think this. Wait,
Hassan could have a thought like this now. Hassan could totally
believe this. Now, by the way, he could totally think something.
Lots of feminists think this that all like unjustified and tend
to
there's a huge contingent of feminists who truly believe that
he's okay but I'm telling you that's not like an that's not not
like a totally innane belief. Okay. Anyway, we keep going. No,
no, you're not you're not someone who is oppressed by capital
in order to perform labor that they might otherwise not perform.
What a sweet talking point. No, I have it on good authority from
the brothel owner actually that Hassan requested the daughter
of a billionaire to be his prostitute that he actually paid for
the daughter of a billionaire specifically. So there was no material
concern. So actually it's totally consensual. We're fine. We're
fine. Connor, we're fine. >> Bye Sam. Love you. Have a
good weekend. >> It's all fine. Present day. They're actually
100% compliant with Germany's prostitution protection act. When
the public prosecutor's office tried to salvage some remaining
charges out of this case, the court rejected all of them. And
it's noted here that Rafford indictment in Berlin to be considered
so weak that it doesn't even open a trial. As a result of all
this, the local government publicly apologized at the Argus rifle
and compensated them almost $300,000 for damages caused. Now,
>> is Connor gonna contend with that? Is Connor going to
contend with the fact that apparently very very often even like
any indictment goes to trial in >> There is one truthful
element to this story. The raid was prompted by a witness whose
abusive older boyfriend had been forcing her to work at the brothel
and she was reportedly underage. Her pimp was sentenced to 7
years for this. But this was just one criminal using an otherwise
legal venue to exploit somebody. This wasn't the brothel itself
trafficking kids. And the only reason you would ever care Hold
on. So, a 17-year-old shows up to the >> Hold on.
and enters into work. But that's not >> But hold on. Was
the Was the 17-year-old engaging in sex work at the brothel?
I actually I don't know the full story here. Was the 17-year-old
even engaging in sex work at the brothel or was she being trafficked
via the brothel cuz they knew people were there to buy? I actually
have no idea. >> Indications of a child being entered into
work because Germany the age of consent is 15 in the brothel.
Employed a 17-year-old for work, but nothing to see
Wait,
is that just totally legal to to have like a 17-year-old prostitute
in Germany? That can't be the case, right? Germany. Hello, Germany.
Hello, Germany. Please tell me that's not true.
>> that's brilliant analysis. Dilo, good >> Jesus.
Meanwhile, hold on. Isn't he boys with Queen? Disney boys with
you know isn't isn't Destiny a
isn't Destiny because he a 40-year-old man who was posing as
a seven as a 19-year-old worker who actually ended up being >> I
mean I do suspect Destiny is a I just have no evidence for it
yet I do suspect he is a so thank you thank you very much Connor
yes let me get this straight per totally innocent of any power
dynamics any abuse any use of workers in the oppressive system
of capitalism totally nothing murder club Artemis totally innocent
no big deal the state prosecutor's office just made up the entire
case whole cloth. But simultaneous to you stating those facts,
okay, a 17-year-old was employed at the brothel that Hassan [__]
engaged with a worker, but it's not a big deal because they weren't
running kids. Okay, but let's leave that as one.
>> Is Connor not going to engage in the the timeline at
all? Is he just going to keep making things up?
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Now, Destiny is
because he was
Now, Destiny is a
>> That's really funny >> because he was a 40-year-old
man posing as a 19-year-old sex worker when the 19-year-old sex
worker was actually 17 and a half. Let's not >> 18-year-old
worker to be fair, but nobody [__] said that. I'm
saying that there is a stark
>> that does Conor Connor seems to know a lot about this
while not knowing the
like the the timeline isn't in contention here >> difference
in the level of criticism being levied at either party. I I just
want you to think about the stark difference in the way that
Hassan is being swept for and >> isn't it just like weird
like this is
propaganda, isn't it? That like you just can't see like Wait,
why are you defending this? Like it doesn't make any sense to
me. Wait, why are you why are you like weirdly bringing up Destiny
right now to complain about this? Like you're doing a bad job,
but just why did you think this was a way you could you just
wanted to throw in like Destiny's actually like not as bad as
you guys think? I I just don't know why you would do that. Well,
I do know why you would do that, but
>> Is being vilified
venue to exploit somebody. This wasn't the brothel itself trafficking.
And the only reason you would ever care about someone supporting
a business where something like this happened is if the business
itself did something that led to it happening. And following
an extremely thorough investigation, a court rejection, and a
formal apology from the city, that pretty clearly seems to not
be the case here. So, if you're telling me your standard is that
all 100,000 people who visit the brothel each year are child
because of this one isolated incident, I just think you're lying.
It's been speculated that the primary reason for the rate was
actually that the city was missing out on substantial tax revenue
because of the pay structure of the workers. Now, we can't know
if that's true or not, but it is entirely possible that this
whole thing had almost nothing to do with that one incident at
the >> We we're we're holding up a news article that says
how Angel's rival raided by 900 officers says German police.
We're not going to not going to dig into that one a little bit.
>> And to top it all off, that lone isolated incident happened
6 years after Hassan visited Germany. So, this entire claim about
Hassan is built. Okay. Yes. Hold on. Destiny being a idiot again.
Of course. If Assan is going to reach hard to say that I kickstarted
his career, then I'm responsible for his career 10 times over.
Also was [__] 15-year-old when he was visiting that
broth in Bland. That's why he doesn't like to talk about it as
much now. Yeah. I don't think Dustin knows that for a fact. I
don't think he knows that at all. Same thing with [__]
taco. But saying that Hassan, the socialist who thinks that people
are enslaved by the system of >> Dude, Connor,
this is you're really embarrassing. This is really shameful.
This is like totally shameful stuff. >> And paid to bangitute
in violation. Like if you think that the woman's a slave, she
can't consent. If the worker is a part of a system that makes
her a slave. >> Okay. All right. Somebody
somebody get me the clip of Destiny talking about the girl who
was like he's pretty sure was traffic and he still got a from
them. Holy. You ever you you ever paid for a prostitute before
in a legal state? >> Um I don't know if it's legal. I actually
did one time very recently here cuz I was curious one of those
massage places or whatever and I was like I'm curious what this
is like. Okay, it's quarantine time. >> How was it? >> Um
probably one of the worst experiences of my life. >> Was
it just like a sad or >> Yes. For like and I like tipped
really well too cuz I was like, "Oh, you know, I got a lot of
money. These girls seem they don't make much. Like maybe they'll
be It was horrible." Was it from like an older woman or >> She
was probably like in her 30s or 40s. >> Yeah, it was really
bad. >> Like the scenario is actually kind of sad to me.
Like like I don't know like I have to pull out my phone and use
like Google Translate so that this woman understands what I'm
saying. It feels like she's like some slave trafficked in and
it's like this is kind of awkward.
>> What are we
feel about this and maybe you'll be really good at Lucy giving?
It's like nope man. >> Okay. Um, >> want you for
a moment to imagine if Hassan said this.
This would be playing on CNN if Hassan said this. Okay. >> Yeah.
But are you like a fast stroker or kind of like a slow stroker,
dude? >> Um, I mean, I'll do >> I'm good. I'm good.
Thanks, man. That was not a gay question at all. That was not
the gayest question I've ever heard in my life at all. We're
back to call. >> She can't consent.
>> That was just a totally insane question to ask. I have
no idea why you did that just now. That was insane.
God damn it. These people, man. Your child trafficking claim
about his son is built on a story about one incident that happened
6 years after he was there at a brothel that was never even charged
with anything and was compensated for the investigation. And
as a side note, I also want to mention that Artemis ended up
donating said compensation to a children's hospital. So, happy
endings. This whole once again, all right, I would have to see
Kilo's specific argu I would have to check his [__]
Twitter. So, I know that I'm associating Jaytock's quotes and
Queen's quotes and everybody's quotes about Destiny to just Kilo.
I know I'm doing like the guilt by association thing, but I'm
pretty sure >> what are my quotes? I while I am willing
to joke that Desty's a rapist, I like now after everything, it
is just a joke. And I literally said, well, I don't have I I
know it's true. I just don't have the evidence for it yet.
But what are my quotes? What are the quotes that you >> with
all these dudes? So, Destiny
because he and >> I I never I've never called this guy
in any sincere sense. Connor, come on, man.
I know Quean has not either.
We will we will joke about this
and laugh about it. We're not arguing it sincerely. Holy buddy
videos to a 40-year-old man posing as a 19-year-old worker who
was actually 17 and a half. Hassan [__] didn't do
nothing and Artemis didn't do nothing despite employing a 17-year-old.
Make it make sense. I can't. >> Story is really just a
lazy way to desperately try to attach bad things. So, while the
underlying facts about this claim are somewhat true, the implications
about Hassan that people make from them are deliberately misleading.
I'm okay with that. Hold on. Hold on. Let's salvage my my dislike
of the segment. Claim: Hassan visited a problem in Germany that
was ready for trafficking. Misleading. I would put this little
bar thing more in the middle. That's fine. We're not that far
off. He's not calling it. So, that's good. Next claim. Han threatened
US senator. You may remember from earlier that one of tweets
actually alleges that Hassan is threatening two US senators.
So, no, this isn't about Rick Scott. This is about Tom Cotton,
senator from Arkansas, who in 2024 posted a tweet encouraging
people stuck behind pro Palestinian protesters to take matters
into your own hands. He then went on Fox News and suggested that
in Arkansas protesters would be thrown off bridges. >> Something
like this happened in Arkansas on a bridge there. Let's just
say I think there'd be a lot of very wet criminals that have
been tossed overboard, not by law enforcement, but by the people
whose uh road they're >> In response, quote, tweet cotton
with a diagram of the homemade shotgun used in the assassination
of former Japanese prime minister Shinab. So, is this a threat?
Technically, yes. >> This is going to be the one this unfortunately
is going to be the one where I agree with Conor and disagree
that chatter that was calling. >> I think I think Kila
went too far with this one. >> But to be clear, an elected
official was calling for violence against the American public
and I'm supposed to object to somebody using a meme to threaten
him back. Look, maybe this is just me, but if our elected leaders
start threatening us with frankly, I kind of hope that someone
would threaten them back. So you can say Assan's response here
was irresponsible or stupid if you want. But to say I sound friend
the US senator while ignoring that it was a response to a call
to violence is at best seriously >> Oh maybe maybe I would
give Hold on. No, maybe I don't disagree. Maybe I don't disagree
with Kilo on this one. I think I actually argued this with him
earlier today actually or maybe even last night and I think I
came to I was like oh yeah maybe I don't. Why do I feel like
I got a Yeah, he said the thing and it's true that he threatened
to sitting US senator but the US senator said something wild
first. Therefore this is not true. What >> I like disagree
with it in most ways because I I just think the calls to violence
even in response to other calls to violence are probably inappropriate
sometimes and I do think this would have been a time where it
was inappropriate but it's said was a senator deserves a >> Next
said that Ela Klein was a valid military target. This one got
picked up >> Okay, this one is I'll give Kilo this. I will
give Kilo this before the segment even starts.
>> If I remember correctly, Hassan was being descriptive
about combatants in a combat zone and the commentary bros were
saying, "Oh, Hassan is calling for her right now." Ethan started
claiming that Hassan was calling for violence against her and
as gold was similarly >> If somebody attacks Hila Klein,
they're going to go to jail. Why is he telling people this? Why
would he be said? What is wrong with you? He's making a direct
call for violence. That's insane. Oh my god. But here's what
Hassan actually >> Any kind of violence that Israeli settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences in the West Bank. >> It's
not even true. You goddamn. He spent time earlier in the video
and or after this debunking the baby settler statement. If if
literally any violence that happens to settlers in the West Bank
is justified, if you add on to that, there are baby settlers
by inference. Wouldn't you arrive at the logical inference that
everybody has made that Hassan has said that babies are legitimate
targets of violence? And when you couple that with Hamas actually
shooting and slaughtering children,
>> if you look at the context, it's about the IDF and their
actions in area B >> on October 723 and his tepid response
to October 723, doesn't that lead you to think that he's a jihad
sympathizer? What the >> resistance against an occupying
military force? I cannot repeat this enough. every type of armed
resistance against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying
force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite
podcasters like uh wife that participate in these raids. The
violence that the Palestinians engage in in an act of resistance
against this illegal occupying force is literally legal. Definitionally
legal. So killing combatants is not legal. You
excuse me, killing non-combatants if I said
I'm going to have to watch this again on Monday in order to rip
this segment apart. The second >> the wall is in the Bahamas,
right? I think it's ba rain. You got the ba at the beginning
first at the beginning, right? But it's in the Middle East. I
think it's called Bahrain is where the the wall is. Yeah, I think
so. >> Sucks so much ass. >> Clearly Hassan is discussing
international law as it relates to resistance against military
forces in illegally occupied territory. >> No, he said
settlers too. You >> he says violent actions against settlers
who are conducting military operations in these territories is
completely fine. >> He didn't say conducting military operations.
You're adding that >> resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot repeat this enough. Every type of armed resistance
against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force
in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite. any resistance
against an occupying force that implies combatants like militants.
And then he says he says settlers and the IOF, the IDF. I do
think that that one's a little close. I think that one's a little
close.
Like Connor does appear to be correct. If you think settlers
means all settlers, I think he's clearly talking about militants.
for podcasters like Wife that participate in these raids. >> Like
he's talking about people with guns and uniforms in this case.
I >> violence that the Palestinians engage in in an act
of resistance against this illegal occupying force is literally
legal. Definitionally legal. So killing combatants is not legal.
You
>> excuse me, killing non-combatants. If I said combatants,
I'm going to have to watch this again on Monday in order to rip
this segment. >> So Hassan was quite obviously not saying
that somebody should attack Ela's client. He said that people
engaged in military operations in illegally occupied territory
are under international law meal targets like Elila would have
been while she was doing that. So whether his son is correct
or not, the way the clients presented his statements here and
>> dude, I watched a lot more of this. I think it's unambiguous
that he's talking about militants in this case, I'm pretty sure
it's unambiguous. >> People reported on him is completely
wrong. Okay. I feel like some of his language was sweepy. I'm
okay with people saying that like Hassan was not calling for
active violence about Heloclein right now. I could make inferences
based off of other statements in order to arrive at that conclusion.
Okay, we're done. We're done with the Connor stuff. Oh my god.
Thank god. Thank god the Connor stuff is over. We made it. We
made it all the way through. We're okay. We're okay. Okay, we're
coming out the other side. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.